peuples autochtones. Julie Émond
a préparé ce qui suit.
(chants)
- D'un bout à l'autre du pays,
des cérémonies ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui pour souligner
l'héritage des peuples
autochtones.
CONSTANT AWASHISH, grand chef,
Conseil de la Nation Atikamekw
- L'éducation,
la sensibilisation, c'est ça,
je pense, l'arme la plus
importante pour combattre
tout le racisme envers
les Autochtones, et j'espère
qu'aujourd'hui pourra
contribuer à ça.
- Une journée importante,
notamment pour ne pas oublier
les horreurs vécues dans
les pensionnats autochtones.
SAMIAN, rappeur anichinabé
originaire de Pikogan
- On entend les discours
aujourd'hui des survivants
des pensionnats qui commencent
à parler depuis peut-être
une dizaine d'années
de ce qui s'est passé. C'est
comme si on les entendait,
mais on les écoutait pas.
- À Ottawa, l'une
des recommandations du Comité
vérité et réconciliation
a récemment été appliquée.
En juin, le Parlement a adopté
à l'unanimité le projet de loi
C-5, qui crée la Journée
nationale pour la vérité
et la réconciliation.
Elle aura lieu le 30 septembre.
STEVEN GUILBEAULT
ministre du Patrimoine canadien
- Ce sera au départ un congé
férié pour les employés fédéraux
pour que notre société
reconnecte le plus possible
avec cette réalité, avec
les traditions, mais aussi
avec les peuples autochtones
au Canada.
- Le premier ministre du Québec
n'envisage pas d'imiter
le fédéral.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
- Écoutez, on n'est pas
en faveur d'ajouter des journées
fériées pour quelques raisons
que ce soit au Québec.
On en a, toutes proportions
gardées, déjà beaucoup.
- Si le gouvernement du Québec
veut démontrer une certaine
ouverture envers les peuples
autochtones, démontrer
également leur intérêt
à la réconciliation, je pense
que ça serait la moindre
des choses de pouvoir adopter
une journée fériée en l'honneur
des peuples autochtones.
- Les Territoires du Nord-Ouest
et le Yukon ont déjà décrété
que la Journée nationale
des Autochtones du 21 juin
serait fériée sur
leur territoire.
Ici Julie Emond,
Radio-Canada, M